date night for you guys tonight how
awesome is it to come out tonight you're
being honored and spend a little time I
was the one that was like we might go
out after this and he's like I'm already
tired babe you have a newborn at home
that takes a lot it's true tired it's
like 8:15 I totally understand we're
exhausted so you probably won't be going
out but she's gonna pump on the way to
this bar that's all I do I pumped I come
to nights like this every once in awhile
and I pump again you're receiving their
Cori Courage Award tonight what do you
think makes her the most courageous what
makes her the most courageous she
doesn't in the face of beer she doesn't
back down that's for sure I've seen her
do things that I can't imagine doing
myself and I'm very proud of her and I'm
in awe of her for some of the things
that she is able to do when she sets her
mind to it so
it's true Nathan I want to cry on
Entertainment Tonight I'm crying that
was so amazing um why is it important
for you guys to come out and support
tonight date night could have been
movies that could have been massages it
could have been something to just relax
but you're here a huge honor and I grew
up with Rita and Kate and so for them to
ask if I would you come be a part of
this evening was just in itself a huge
honor I've done a lot of work with the
PCRF it's like a big thing for me to
stay involved with that and I do a lot
of work through my company with them and
so it's just something I'm really
passionate about it's one of the things
that I will always be you know what I
think cancer hits close to home for all
of us whether it's women's cancers or
all cancer so I'm just it's an important
important to show up I think that we'll
see probably another big party in about
six weeks for your big birth the next
time you guys get all dressed out up do
you have plans and like give it to me
Kate on an Anniston level like do you go
full Anniston for the fortieth or do you
keep it like low-key it's Paul Aniston
from what I heard invited so you know
full it's gonna be a full I'm just gonna
go for it I love you know I love a party
I want a party yeah she loves a good
party any excuse for an Aniston level
party
so much it's so nice to me